que Josiane et veine potière de son état
exerce ce métier depuis une quinzaine
d'années une terre d'argile d'une grande
finesse appelée faïence blanche lui sert
de matière première pour faire naître de
ses mains de précieux objets d'art d'une
grande diversité de la tortue miniature
au luminaire et autres pots elle partage
avec nous les gestes subtils et
l'imagination qui exige cette profession
j'ai commencé la poterie la
commercialisation d'un peu près avec des
animaux siffleurs
en 84 c'était bon c'était peut-être des
animaux moins sophistiqués mais il y
avait toute une gamme les escargots
bonsoir
c'est à l'origine des signaux aux
enfants parce que j'avais beaucoup de
mal à commercialiser de ce que je
fabrique et je faisais des expositions à
l'époque et j'avais du mal à j'étais
très mal à l'aise et en trouvant ce
petit ces petits objets siffleur j'avais
le public des enfants et c'était bien
agréable ça me donnait du courage et ça
a été le pied dans la commercialisation
parce que fabriquer c'est bien mais
vendre aussi c'est bien il faut et je
crois que c'est peut-être plus difficile
pour l'artisan aussi c'est commercialisé
il faut être sûr de soi il faut on a
toujours des fois on n'est pas trop
surtout quand on commence on n'est pas
sûr de soi et on dévalorise un petit peu
sans ces objets c'est ce qu'on fabrique
alors ça c'est de la terre que j'ai que
j'ai préparé que j'ai passé dans dans
cette machine c'est une boudineuse pour
bien la travailler pour que je puisse
tourner plus aisément que ma terre soit
de bonne qualité je passe ma terre dans
cette machine qui me fait des boudins et
d'où son nom la boudineuse
les poupées cette vidéo
et donc
ça m'évite ce travail ce travail
physique que faisait que font aussi
encore quelques potiers traditionnels là
je prends ma terre je fais seulement que
des boules je n'ai plus de travail de
malaxage
avant c'était un gros travail c'est
aussi une histoire de temps
bon
c'est
pas pour cette quantité de terre quand
c'est des gros pots oui il faut il faut
donner mais quand là c'est une petite
boule c'est surtout le geste la façon
dont vous placez les mains qui font que
ça se fait facilement
c'est c'est pas dans la force qu'on l'a
c'est plutôt dans le geste ça ça demande
un peu de temps à avoir donc le premier
temps c'est c'est bien travailler la
terre la montée
là faire une jolie quille et la
descendre
et si je veux faire des choses petites à
ce moment là je ne travaillerai que sur
le sommet de ma mode de terre
pour que ça soit
oh à ce moment-là on rétrécira on fera
une forme toute façon souvent on part
d'une forme cylindrique
en monte et là après on soit on resserre
soit on écarte suivant ce qu'on veut
faire c'est toujours la même technique
quel que soit
les potiens ont chacun son geste un peu
quoi il y a très peu de gestes officiel
moi j'ai pas eu de maître en tournage
j'ai appris moi-même
ici même à la Réunion
après
tu as une quinzaine d'années de pratique
voilà on n'a pas besoin de formation
forcément pour ça ça facilite énormément
de choses actuellement bon c'était je
trouve qu'il y a 20 ans on pouvait
peut-être se permettre de se former tout
seul d'avoir le temps mais actuellement
moi je conseille aux jeunes de passer
par un apprentissage par une formation
par une école pas c'est un gain de temps
terrible c'est plus rapide c'est plus
rapide bon il y a après une fois qu'on a
les bases après rien de toute façon il y
a toujours des choses à découvrir à
rechercher à
il y a toujours des choses à s'enrichir
sur le dans son métier
et donc on a on a une clientèle locale
qui nous amène régulièrement les gens
l'extérieur et
on a les clientèle de passage les
touristes les vrais
c'est une équipe de France oui vous
travaillez ensemble vous faites
exactement les mêmes choses c'est le
travail à la chaîne
on a un peu nos spécialités mais on est
polyvalent aussi bon je sais c'est vrai
que dans l'atelier je suis par exemple
la seule à tourner
madame Ariel ça serait la spécialiste
des dessins des cocotiers
voilà je tourne voilà et comme ça je
peux je peux recommencer par exemple si
je veux faire un couvercle je vais pas
tourner un couvercle tout ça je vais
tourner mon couvercle comme ça dans ce
sens là
et là il va y avoir un deuxième temps de
travail
on essuie toujours la boue on essaie de
sortir l'objet
plus propre possible pour pas qu'il est
trop de travail voilà et ce couvercle il
sera travaillé dans un second temps
justement sur ce Tour là je réserve à ça
dans ce sens-là de savoir combien
d'objets vous faites à peu près par jour
s'il vous plaît si je tourne je peux
tourner une cinquantaine une centaine de
pièces mais quand je
suis bien rare que je tourne sans pièce
par jour mais j'ai une journée de
travail j'ai une semaine de décoration
derrière
pour pour une journée de tournage j'ai
facilement 8 jours de travail derrière
avec les filles
je conçois pas du tout les autres petits
comme de la concurrence la concurrence
elle est pas là la concurrence elle est
dans les objets importés
le nombre le problème c'est les
soi-disant artisans qui
qui produisent ça qui importe ça alors
ça c'est terrible pour nous on peut pas
on peut pas concurrencer donc ce sont
des objets qui ont été empilés les uns
sur les autres pour mettre pour faire
cuire la première cuisson on met
beaucoup de choses dans le four on
superpose bon comme c'est des objets qui
sont qui sont fragiles lorsque l'on met
on peut les superposer quand même mettre
les petits objets dans les objets un peu
plus gros et donc ça c'est la première
cuisson l'objet est cuit c'est à dire
qu'il sonne il doit il doit bien
raisonner et à ce moment là on va faire
un petit dépoussiérage et on va mettre
les couleurs on a on a choisi cette
terre blanche pour pouvoir justement
travailler les couleurs avoir toute une
gamme de couleur on a fait des essais
sur des terres rouges et les couleurs ne
ressortent pas aussi bien donc comme on
est dans une île de couleur ça sera de
la couleur qui aura dessus
là c'est une cuisson qui monte à 1020
degrés il faut 8 heures de monter en
température et 24 heures de
refroidissement vous pouvez toucher
c'est encore chaud ça c'était ça s'est
arrêté hier matin
là là ce sont c'est une cuisson qui
monte à
960 960 980
la cuisson aussi est en 8 heures et donc
autant de temps pour refroidir 24 heures
et c'est
par cette magie de cette cuisson que les
couleurs vont se fixer et se révéler
aussi
donc la première étape
le biscuit ce qu'on appelle de biscuit
il y a des amis la dernière cuisson
au moment pour faire des étagères à
l'intérieur là aucun objet ne doit se
toucher un tout doit être séparé donc ça
fait des enfants non beaucoup plus
aériens après le dépoussiérage on fait
un débarbouillage un barbouillage c'est
à dire qu'on va passer la couleur sur
l'écran de
surfaces pour pour faire des fonds